stubborn fat that's something we all
have issues with
well we now have a non-invasive solution
just in time for bathing suit season
let's welcome back brittany from the
jazzy wellness brittany tell everyone
what body contouring is
and how does it work so body contouring
is a non-surgical treatment that
permanently kills the fat and tightens
the skin
so how many sessions are needed to start
seeing results
so in your first session typically
you'll see two to three inches but we've
had patients lose up to seven
so tell me about what are some of the
areas because stubborn fats all over the
body what are some of the areas that you
guys treat
pretty much everywhere we do the stomach
the back arms
legs neck we're seeing these before and
after photos
so how long do these results last
stunning results how long do they last
so the fat that we kill is permanently
gone so it can never come back but the
skin
can only hold the laxity as long as
you're aging
but we can reverse it back a little bit
instead of pushing it forward
we just saw we're looking at these
results at this person's stomach
incredible how long does the session
take how long are you there for for one
session
for about an hour and it's and so okay
so talking about the actual process what
does it feel like what do they
experience when it comes to you guys so
we use multiple different technologies
the first one liquefies the fat cells
the second one kills the fat cells and
then the third one
tightens the skin so mostly i've had
patients fall asleep but if they're
awake they've described it as a hot
stone massage
that sounds comforting a hot stone
massage so is it true that patients are
losing
two inches the same day two to three but
like i said we've seen up to seven so it
just depends on the person
seven so i can come see you on a friday
somebody come see you on a friday they
lose
seven inches and go out to the pool on a
saturday they're seven inches smaller
yep that's that's yeah we say it so
calmly that is incredible that's amazing
brittany we always appreciate you
joining the show thank you so much
thanks for having me all right so the
jazzy wellness is located at 900 south
valley view boulevard
suite 100 find them online at
thejazzywellness.com
and they got a great special take
advantage of this special deal
guaranteed
lose two inches the same day first 10
callers get 40
off a series of body contouring call
today
702 800 740
las vegas now will